[Applaudissements]
l'air du temps
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quand on m'a
proposé de venir ici pour parler de
l'air du temps j'ai pensé à tous les
sujets qui ont déjà été présentées et je
me suis cassé la communication
l'internet
la connexion avec le monde entier je
peux envoyer un message à mes amis
what's up au mexique pour leur dire
regarde maintenant je suis sûr tadic ce
jeu peut aussi voyager partir à
l'étranger et je pense que beaucoup
d'entre nous sont déjà partis pour un
stage pour des études ou même pour vivre
à l'étranger et donc on est connecté
avec l'autre avec d'autres cultures et
on rajoute à tous à de nouvelles
technologies qui se développe à une
vitesse qui fait presque peur et dans
tout ça vous et moi on fait comment
quand on fait face à ce changement
comment est-ce qu'on s'adapte en tant
qu'être humain dans nos entreprises
d'aujourd'hui mais surtout pour être là
demain
alors moi j'accompagne les gens dans le
changement
j'ai dans le changement est dans
l'interculturel donc entre les cultures
est une chose que je vois assez souvent
quand je parle de gestion du changement
en entreprise
c'est cette tête là surtout n'en parle
pas d'un côté on a des managers qui
disent à la gestion du non non ils vont
résister j'en veux pas je on va essayer
on va mettre des formations en place on
va on va tout faire mais on sait déjà
ils vont résister et de l'autre côté
quand je parle avec des employés qui
sont en train de travailler dans ces
fameuses entreprises en changement ils
me disent tu sais il ya des efforts de
changement ont fait des formations ont
fait plein de trucs à ça c'est sûr mais
moi mon problème d'ordinateur que j'ai
tous les jours personne ne le règle
alors on peut vouloir aller plus vite
parce que c'est l'art du temps mais moi
je peux pas mon pc fonctionne pas et
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
où des murs se crée entre les chefs
d'entreprise les chefs d'equipe et les
employés
ceux qui pensent que la résistance est
un problème et les autres qui disent
banon mon problème c'est que mes
problèmes ne sont pas résolus
et j'imagine à chaque fois quand je
parle avec ces gens ce qu'ils
préféraient avoir laissé plutôt cette
tête là des gens
un peu trop vite des gens qui viennent
ensemble et qui se retrouvent autour
d'une table et kiko créer des solutions
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu créer des
solutions
ça veut dire d'enlever ces fameux mur
concret dans l'aude en notant dans notre
tête et de créer des ponts devenir les
uns avec les autres
regardez le problème en face et dire ça
y est vous fait quoi et pour ça au
travers de mon travail à l'étranger ça
va faire plus de dix ans que je voyage
entre la france et d'autres pays
j'ai eu l'opportunité de voir comment
d'autres cultures voit le changement
mais aussi comment différents types
d'entreprises de la petite start up qui
vient de naître et qui a envie de
changer le monde à la tpe pme et la
grande entreprise internationale avec
plus de 5 millions
5000 employés et quoi qu'il arrive le
changement c'est toujours je me prends
la tête je veux pas aux non ça va être
un problème
ça va être difficile et comment peut-on
mettre en place la deuxième photo da ces
gens qui co créé comment on fait ça et
bien le secret se trouve dans ce que moi
j'appelle la transculturalité l'inter
culturalité ces deux cultures qui se
rencontrent mais qui se mélangent pas et
la transculturalité ce sont deux
cultures qui se rencontrent et qui en
créent une deuxième une troisième et
elles se mélangent
quand je parle de culture c'est pas
seulement la culture françaises ou
allemandes ou américaines c'est aussi la
culture en entreprise les gens qui
travaillent en dans le marketing ne vont
pas avoir la même culture que les gens
qui travaillent dans la finance parce
qu'ils ont d'autres buts et d'autres
d'autre but à atteindre et d'autres
manières d'atteindre leur but
alors c'est quoi le secret eh bien je
vais vous partager trois piliers qui
peuvent vous permettre à vous en tant
qu'individu en entreprise et en tant que
chef d'équipé en tant qu'employé de
mettre en place ces changements de
manière à ce que ça soit de la
co-création et pas du jeu créé un mur et
on verra bien ce qui se passe après
alors le premier pilier c'est ce que
j'appelle la perspective multiples
ça veut dire quoi la perspective
multiples l'a déjà on est dans une salle
avec plein de personnes et chacun en
train de regarder quelque chose de
différent et vous allez interpréter ce
que vous entendez d'une manière vraiment
différente
il ya des gens qui vont adorer ce que je
dis d'autres qui vont trouver ça
ennuyeux
le doute qui vont détester et pourtant
on fait la même expérience par mener en
train de vivre le même moment et donc la
multi dimensionnalité c'est d'accepter
que l'on a des visions différentes et
qu'elles sont enrichissantes et pas
merkel sont enrichissantes
elles enrichissent parce que si je sais
que ma façon de voir le monde et de
telle manière et que quelqu'un d'autre
peut voir le monde complètement
différemment les portes des possibilités
s'ouvrent qui est-ce qui est donc
possible l'idée quand on veut mettre en
place un changement c'est de créer une
carte de ce que l'on voit et de prendre
toutes les perspectives possibles et du
diable tu vois le changement comment toi
et toi tu crois que c'est quoi le
problème à moi j'avais cru que c'était
ça essaie de rentrer en discussion de
détruire ces petits murs concret et
d'ouvrir les perspectives
la deuxième option le deuxième pilier
s'appelle des acteurs connectés alors
avec internet au tout ça en ad
simplicité pour mettre en place une
connexion entre des gens dans le monde
entier
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire vraiment
être des acteurs connectés ça veut dire
que quand on veut changer quelque chose
en général on a un problème où on veut
améliorer quelque chose mais en gros où
on veut passer d'un point a à un point b
et on se demande mais où est le problème
ah ben on est trop lent ah ben on perd
des clients notre chiffre d'affaires se
casse la figure
il va falloir changer quelque chose mais
ça ce ne sont que des symptômes
comment faire il faut trouver la racine
du problème pourquoi sommes-nous l'on
est ce que c'est parce qu'on a des
processus qui sont un peu trop vieux est
ce que c'est parce qu'on est trop dans
la cause la hiérarchie et on partage pas
d'informer les informations un peu pas
assez la question c'est où se trouve le
problème est ensuite quelle est la
personne qui la plus proche du problème
pour le décrire et donc on revient à
notre carte ou son
les fameuses perspective il ya une fois
qu'on a compris où sont ces fameuses
acteurs on leur donne les outils s'ils
ne les ont pas pour résoudre le problème
donc si je suis pas douée en
informatique j'appelle un informaticien
qui veut dire qu'en fait-on problème
c'est que tu as oublié de mettre à jour
son logiciel
bon bah problème qui dure depuis trois
mois résolu en cinq minutes la troisième
perspective le troisième pilier qui est
important à mettre en place c'est
d'expérimenter de manière itérative et
l'idée de l'expérimentation et
interactive c'est de répéter un
changement jusqu'à ce que sa faveur en
fonctionne mais le conseil que je donne
toujours c'est ne jamais changer tout un
système d'un coup mais de prendre son
temps de faire sa fameuse carte de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise quel est le véritable
problème de trouver les acteurs qui sont
le plus proche possible du problème et
de regarder ensemble ce qu'on pourrait
faire
quel est le micro changements qu'on
pourrait mettre en place qui pourrait
tout changer
j'ai accompagné dans ce avec ce pilier
de trois idées
une entreprise qui avait d'énormes
problèmes au niveau de son propre
processus rh et en fait il faisait tout
sur papier ils m'ont dit bon on aimerait
bien digitalisées mais on sait pas ce
que ça veut dire mais on fait quoi on
ad'abord cartographier donc on a fait
cette perspective multiples qu'est-ce
qui se passe où sont les acteurs on les
a trouvés et ensuite on à connecter les
acteurs qui avait les connaissances du
processus et des acteurs qui avait les
connaissances en informatique et on a
fait des micros changements ces
libations d'essayer d'abord dû utiliser
excel ça donnerait quoi
eh bien on entité allant simplement un
petit outil excellent on a réussi à
passer de quinze jours de processus à 10
alors pour une entreprise c'est énorme
cinq jours de gagner avec cinq personnes
qui travaillent en même temps je vous
laisse faire le calcul jeu ça fait
beaucoup
et donc ce modèle si vous arrivez à le
mettre en place pour vous dans votre
entreprise en vous disant d'abord qu'est
ce que je vois qu'est ce que je
comprends qui est le plus proche du
problème et qui peut m'aider à le
résoudre et comment on peut faire des
mini test pour voir ce qui marche
vous serez arrivé au coeur du changement
et s'il ya une chose juste une chose que
vous pouviez retenir de la soirée
ça serait construisons des ponts plutôt
que des murs
[Applaudissements]